okay so we are here to discuss movie
news and we're gonna milk this fucker
for all its fucking work so yes this is
about the yet even more ghostbusters
news we'll get to what we thought about
like the whole Ghostbusters 3 thing and
stuff like that but this is in response
to the news that that we've heard about
their Ghostbusters 3 its Ghostbusters
reboot yeah I like it is it even is it a
reboot or is it whatever it's not even
reboot Ghostbusters just goes yeah it's
not likely Kristen Wiig is gonna play
dan Aykroyd do you know so it's like is
that a three if that reboot whatever its
kind of its own thing REE Buster's there
you go so this is this is responsive
prema trying to make like a franchise I
guess like not just on a movie but like
they're doing a couple spin-off movies
and stuff like that you've done more
research is what I scribbled down
so apparently Sony is forming something
called ghost corpse or ghost core and
what you do with that s in core but I
don't know if it's plural or not so it's
hot could be a quirks like that it's
either ghost corpse no there's no II so
it's like the ghost corpse or like ghost
corporations or ghost core as in one
corporation or or an army core anyway
what they do it yeah so they're forming
this little division at Sony and they're
bringing in Ivan Reitman and Dan Aykroyd
to quote-unquote scare up new branding
opportunities Reitman and Aykroyd claim
that this was always their original idea
anyway that when they did the movie 30
years ago they wanted to dream up this
whole universe or whatever of like
Ghostbusters movies and franchising
opportunities and this and that of
course we know that didn't happen we got
ghostbusters 2 and then the whole thing
disappeared but I actually I can't even
say it disappeared because we had the
cartoon show which was
we good the Ghostbusters were certainly
in video games and the spin-off we've
got video yeah
the video game back which begs the
question do we need more Ghostbusters
movies or could this have just existed
like the Star Wars movies existed in
their own other universe until the
prequels came back well there were books
there were games there were there was
well we'll get to that in a second so
pretty much they're talking about yeah
so they're scaring up new branding
opportunities really hip and as part of
this they're looking at Joe and Anthony
Russo to write and direct now they
actually have a good pedigree because
they took Captain America say branding
uppity other talk about other movies so
kind of like spin-off movies franchises
shows I even think I heard you and free
balloons for the kids you know all that
stuff the the hot thermal mug all that
shit you some ghost ghosts - yeah my
guess is they're talking about that so
the gun Joe manthie Russo they're good
tap them to produce was a produce and
direct to direct and is produced yes /b
yeah yeah most likely star yeah Channing
Tatum to produce and possibly star in
his most tatum way and and then drew
pearce better known as the Iron Man 3
screenwriter yeah to write the script
see there were really ghostbusters they
were just pretending to be that to all
British actors yeah all ghosts will be
played by Ben Kingsley felt like they'll
like bust the ghost that it turns out
it's just like some old Ben Kingsley
show it and Walter Peck would be right
you do that you could have the ghost of
Gandhi and bottom line we're fine with
all of this as long as Walter Peck is in
all of them but that's really the only
thought it would be more fun to insult
me well now it's my success so but okay
so we should probably go back and be
just like people think they're seeing
ghosts but what they're really seeing is
just a
this rehash of an idea that you know
should have just been allowed to die a
dignified death 20 years ago they cost a
franchise they caused a franchise
explosion so ways we trip right just go
back to like I mean where do we start
should we start at the beginning with
with female Ghostbusters even before
that the idea of a Ghostbusters 3 at all
in my opinion I'm sorry really
overexposed here sorry we have the
National lady fan so yeah so
Ghostbusters 2 came out people forgot
they hated it and demanded a
Ghostbusters yeah something amazing
happened it turns out that all of the
people who said Ghostbusters 2 sucks
suddenly changed their mind and we're
just like her Mike so everyone looking
for their next Crystal Skull to complain
about demanded of Ghostbusters 3 and the
original cast they want everyone in
there this script has been bumping
around for eons and apparently Bill
Murray I think wisely decided that they
all look old and this would be silly so
he was the big holdout everyone else was
in and then Harold rain has died and
then I guess Murray was like oh maybe
we're very much paraphrasing it like I
said we're not there we don't know I'm
gonna turn the exposure down I'm get
bliss on automatic as those driving me
nuts are you gonna edit this out of the
final no no this is how you wanted to be
in there but you'll destroy the illusion
yes only automatic did nothing okay I'm
just gonna turn down a few not just yes
because that was driving me insane okay
and now Stu dark who cares control
lighting that's what I should have fix
it in post yes so that fix it right
there this is the spoof so anyway so
finally this reboots been talked about
for years and years and years and the
video we should mention the video game
because the video game many considered
the unofficial Ghostbusters three yeah
well we're back and they yeah and then
the video game was good a Bill Murray
you know sleep walked through it but
minutes it's kind of we've been doing
recently it half the time but you know
that's it's kind of this probably sue
anyone if you want if you want proof
that Ghostbusters
the original cast wouldn't work with
Bill Murray in it like the video games a
good example it just did I just don't
think he cares
mmm like and that's fine like butts in
the bags dude for the Paycheck well yeah
so so okay so finally this Ghostbusters
3 is green lid and they get Paul fake
hopefully I'm saying that right and he
wants to do with an all-female cast with
Kristen Wiig Melissa McCarthy Leslie
Jones I think is her name and I forget
the other ones I'm sorry SNL alumni
basically apparently the only four
female comedians that anybody ever turns
well no I was actually making predicted
I'll say on like maybe Tina Fey maybe
Sarah silver I did get Kristen where you
give Alyssa McCarthy no so I had the
press to me on that that was my
prediction I'm gonna kill the Tina Fey
was Egon amazing but so yeah so this
gets out and people big surprise on the
internet are kind of split you know
something hey great opportunities
whatever others say you know dig up the
course affair and the corpse of your
brain is to bring the ghost of Harold
Ramis that way they can all be together
that that would be amazing
you're dead what do you do I collect
spores molds and fungus on my course you
know in the sea there's two separate
reactions my reaction is generally we
just don't need to do Ghostbusters to
begin with yeah like I'm not I'm just
not into just generally the idea I'm
like it it is what it is again maybe we
should start coming with original ideas
and then there was the reaction take her
my turn Oh chicks it's sexist it's self
exes that they would have for women and
not one guy can you imagine a
Ghostbusters movie
gender we're played by one gender fuckin
crazy
it starts this is the 21st century in
the eighties oh my god I have lots of
girlfriends ah they all come up to me
and they say I read your blog it was
very insightful please take my breath
happens to me all the time as far as I'm
concerned that argument can go straight
to the trash you know if they want to do
a movie with for female coasters I don't
care why because we've already done a
movie before male ghostbusters so at
least it's different
ya know fantasies not only did we do we
did it twice no this is sexist my father
is something that absolutely does not
need to exist at all for the love of God
do something different and this at least
is different so but I mean am I the only
one who was just like well who are who
are the Ghostbusters who's playing them
everyone was immediately reacting till I
you know now or this latest news that
they're doing a spin-off away they're on
that back now like the other extreme
who's playing this is what bat makes me
laugh too because that's like fine then
we'll go back to meiosis I actually
greet in as much then I am always for
doing something new yeah do something
news so the fact that they're like we're
doing male Ghostbusters I'm like but
shoot like how about co-ed then I'm
going to just do co-ed we've had one set
of male one set of female and then you
know the next set if you're going to do
it I don't think you should but if
you're gonna do it I know the internet
and Internet will you stop being a South
Park episode will you stop being the
giant crowd that's always like her
Barbara Barbara Barbara okay we'll do
this the proper Bubba it's like
everything's a fucking hick street you
just relax
do I think the Ghostbusters movie with
the all-female cast is going to be
particularly good you know I will always
wait and see I'm not going to prejudge
and say it's bad from what I know from
my experience I would say probably not
do I think that's going to because be
because it's an all-female cast no it's
going to be because Hollywood sucks
assistant Lee you know you could have
done some good stuff either the heat was
really fucking funny yeah I mean so
maybe I mean maybe it'll work maybe the
studio won't micromanage things I mean
it is Sony we know they have a proud
history of destroying franchises so but
you know to me whether it lives or dies
is not going to be built this time
around I mean the first one was lived or
died based on the cast but I think that
even style of filmmaking is so just it's
gone it's long gone with the 80s and
early like that concept just like well
we can have a cast alone save a goofy
idea there's some movies like like this
is the end or like neighbors and stuff
like that where it's like these are not
especially funny ideas but the cast or
even the Sonics I even something like
the lego movie or something where it's
like the voice acting like written it's
not that funny but the way they work off
each other kind of improvised it makes
it really entertaining III think the
cast Kenny's not how much of the lego
movie was improvised but I maybe will
give you that but what okay this is the
end was as influential as Ghostbusters I
don't know about in okay not maybe that
influential but the stuff that you think
it a good movie you know just nothing
happened all the credit the critics like
the movie in that movie became famous
because it was for guys basically
improvising hmm like if you read the
original script it's funny how little
makes it like it the did you were the
plots there but all these individual
lines are like wow they just maybe were
riffing off each other I don't see that
style of filmmaking really like coming
back and making the impact that
Ghostbusters now that they think in the
Empire
are you a little bit of like maybe not
under practice like I said neighbors is
a big in this is the SR that Seth Rogen
is crowd but are we putting those even
in the same category as ghostbusters no
no but saying that movie is dead I think
it's around it's just not to go sex kind
of movies as being alive and seriously
influential something that could become
as giant as Ghostbusters I don't see
that yeah have you can you think of an
example I mean but not quite to that
extreme but then again like you know
this is the end had a big budget you
know I mean these are films that aren't
just underground indie films and me they
are getting their underground indie
films but no but they must be there some
six out but no not smell super cement
Ghostbuster not to the height of
comparing it to Star Wars there in the
energems I mean it's huge okay no not to
that no no so I don't think they're
going to I don't think they're gonna
live and die by the all-female cast I
think you could cast four cans of soda
you know and it if the movie fails is
just gonna fail because it's not put
together well it's not written well it's
the you know I don't think the casting
is really going to make it the casting
did make the first movie but it's
because the comedians they got you know
were from basically all SNL and the
second city
yeah and second city and because the
director literally just I mean Brightman
would be like here well we'll shoot one
take were you reading the script and
then just go nuts and everybody got in
on the act
hmm so if you're not gonna do that again
and I don't know if he will you know I I
don't know I feel like this is gonna be
way more studio controlled well and then
anything else
in which case is like it doesn't matter
that Jay I'll even bring up even the
ball which is why maybe Paul Fink is
kind of the perfect choice both both
bridesmaids in the heat
I thought work better in the heat but
both of them had kind of a feeling like
they work out working off each other and
improvising in certain scenes like a
lost of his obviously scripted but you
still kind of felt that improv element
in there and
not believing in him I'm like this
trouble this trouble do you think
they're just gonna be like hey here's a
blank check do whatever you want
yeah I'm sure they'll like there's gonna
be like ninja executives spies and
camouflage suit and ties up against the
wall watching everything with binoculars
and scribbling down a million notes
which I've been assigned to be like fix
it fix it fix it like that's what I
think is gonna happen and that's what I
think if this movie dies that's probably
good did you have the goes for him like
a sinister six and you give them all
backgrounds yeah it's gonna be too
manufactured and Ghostbusters the first
one wasn't honestly that was pretty
manufacture it didn't feel like here is
some studio cash-cow dumping ground you
know it became bad because the idea was
well and let's be honest I mean wasn't
cynically started as that it was started
by Dan Aykroyd's you know crazy idea but
like he really believed it well let's be
honest now we're talking us you were
talking about you know the first one
kind of like ghostbusters did just have
this magic combination at the right
timing and lightning struck I mean ya
know he can strike no ice yeah and the
perfect really kind of the perfect proof
of that even though I don't despise the
film or anything is ghostbusters -
everything was the same they brought all
the same people back I got a new villain
and great effects and stuff like that
well that's different problem that that
was that was the problem that was
everything was the same and it wasn't
the same by being the same and actually
just felt like a retread and then even
then there were things like I'm like
really like venkman's playing around
with a one year I died but I mean but
that's what I'm talking about they even
just by getting you know the cast could
make a break in film that was the exact
same cast but it could not save that
movie you know it's still not god-awful
in my opinion but I mean still not a
good sequel okay but I will say this
that can what little there was in
ghostbusters
- is actually made
that caste though true but don't say
don't make it a great movie but honestly
I still consider Ghostbusters too
immensely entertaining despite not
really being a great movie I think it's
you looking you're just like wow this is
really kind of a movie that's saved by
the cast there definitely are and that's
why I don't despise it but ya know like
you kind of said it's an idea that it's
like maybe there are some possibilities
it would be fun to see like maybe kind
of different teams with ghostbusters out
there is something like but I almost see
them more like kind of the video game
world or something like that or like the
comic world it's kind of weird to see
like cuz you can movi view you know
different ways in the comics world and
retain some of what makes it fun for the
people who really like be originally you
know it seemed like the comic world is
timeless the video game world is
timeless you can mess with that you can
get somebody else to do Bill Murray's
voice or you know your mouth yeah you
know it feels like to me it feels like
if someone was to take like Blues
Brothers 2000 years have gone by the
sequels finally coming out it's like re
bloomers 2012 calves you know and stuff
in you wanna know what else we're also
gonna have spin-off movies toy lines and
video games like why don't you wait and
see how the movie does first cuz you
could beat this is my this is my biggest
point I posted this and that was my only
point I'm like listen I mean some of the
names here sound good yeah they could be
great you know I like - Captain America
- you know I you know akroy then Ivan
Reitman have done good work I don't you
know lately I don't know about so much
of what they think ackwards because the
comics one was making a vodka or
something but it is very good vodka is
very delicious it helps make news like
this go down much more smoothly but the
concept of throwing all of these eggs
into one basket before the film is even
released like I don't know I just don't
get it's like shouldn't you make sure
that
this all-female cast that this movie
works first before cuz and I'm sure this
movie will make money because even if
it's terrible the morbidly curious will
show up but if it just does that just
makes money and nobody likes it you know
you've then created you know this whole
division and this whole team to get Leia
I don't know it just seems like they're
really jumping ahead of the game even
Marvel for all the connecting of you
know plot lines to the Avengers me if
any warrant stuff like that I mean they
had x-men they had spider-man they
tested it out a little bit to make sure
it would succeed Sony had spider-man
no no but still it was still Marvel
though that's why I said no but they saw
it's like okay spider-man word x-men
works blade we're okay these are kind of
coming back let's go it was Fox adamant
to but it's still Marvel you know what I
mean I mean the idea of going full force
with like Iron Man and then having
Samuel Jackson at the end it's like the
same comic book movies are okay we can
do this is another huge difference
somebody was comparing this to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
okay fair enough if you want to do a
Marvel Cinematic Universe that's fine
you have to have a universe first yeah
before you do any of this Ghostbusters
doesn't have a universe they had a
cartoon show which was great and they
had two movies and they've got a video
game that is not 57 whatever because a
beautiful mix are you forgiving about
the masterpiece that was extreme
Ghostbusters where everything was
fucking extreme in the nineties I know
they did sir so you have to have like
that base to build from and honestly I
hate to say it as much as I love
Ghostbusters I don't see a giant base
like this giant universe with which to
draw from and say cuz like when Marvel
did this
you've got movies a lot of them which
were kind of smaller like you have the
you had these various movies of like big
small big small in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like not every you know people
will go see big ones but you know not
everybody's gonna see Hulk version 3.0
what version are they on now you know
but some people will definitely be like
oh yeah I'll totally suit up for you
know iron man but even iron man was
almost a surprise hit people were like
oh yeah you know like this actually is
really funny and good like with
ghostbusters that's it that is dname you
don't have other little characters and
stuff to build off of it if one fails
well maybe they see and not have ghosts
smart was based on storylines that
already exists they're just retelling
them now and damn wait it's already
written there just now retelling it
which is tricky don't get me wrong but
it's like this universe is if you listen
to the commentary like this is the other
thing it was Harold Ramos it sounds like
it was Ramos who actually and Reitman
and at least reitman still alive but
they were pulling Aykroyd back a bit and
being like listen this this scripts
freaking nuts the marshmallow man shows
up on page you know yeah so someone's
gonna have to rain
Aykroyd in if he has any role in this
you know creatively or otherwise and you
know part of that team is gone we'd only
have Harold Ramos anymore so I don't
know I don't I just I don't know I think
like anything really it's like you know
a hold out and wait and see you know
what they put out there but the whole
idea of like you know whatever
it can't be all-male can't be all-female
whatever it's like you it would be nice
if they mix it up like it goes all
female to Duke that's fine so the
problem is female that's fine you know
but it's now doesn't destroy it the
problem is not the all-female cast
anybody you want see hear me Katie kick
just it's like the first film had an
all-male cast all you've done is even
did where I start losing it now is it
like well okay we understand that some
of Europe's that they all feel we're
gonna bring an all-male cast and that's
where I'm just like okay if you're gonna
do now a second series in this universe
then make it co-ed like we've that we've
done one with all-male we've done one
with all-female like we're even now go
and you know make it code but it's
almost like are they gonna compete them
is this gonna be like a crossover will
be like Alice kitchen yeah like a female
team in the mail to you
it's just dumb yeah so I mean it's it's
a weird idea that there's like it
doesn't seem like there's a ton of
possibilities for it but again haven't
seen it yet haven't seen where it's
gonna go it's strange to have this much
behind a film that hasn't really proved
itself yet you know in so many years but
I has improved its of with controversy
both unearned like and earned like well
it's Hollywood like in so many years
like yeah I don't know so yeah that's
our big conclusion we don't know
assisted but ya know a lot of it is but
at least we know we don't know unlike
Hollywood which normally just doesn't
know but thinks they know or the
internet its feelin it is it's Jay
Sherman it stinks you haven't even heard
anything about it yet it stinks all
right it's going to stink and then if it
turns out being good I told you just
like I loved ghostbusters 2 to begin
that is my fucking face
it's the brick bring back the people
that make ghostbusters 2 n Ghostbusters
2 that little masterpiece it's like
that's what killed that's what kills me
is I never hated ghostbusters 2 to begin
with but I never loved it yeah I never
liked some people like I their very
small subset of people out there and I
actually like Ghostbusters 2 better than
the first one like and that was from the
beginning and I salute them because that
must have been a rough life that's like
walking into a room and being like oh my
favorite Star Wars characters charge our
Christmas skull amazing the courage you
must have I salute you but um you know I
never hated it to begin with but I never
I never liked that small subset of
people been like oh I love it or retcon
didn't - oh I love it
I'm like no I watched Ghostbusters - and
I'm like there's a lot of things in this
movie that are lame but it is also
really entertaining this is like the
buzzing of flies to me everything
like everyone is around because
everything else is a repeat but but yeah
he was different do you you as new yes
obtain the stuff this is nothing I know
these many advantages to being the
mother of a living I should just be an
edit that's nothing but Y honor scenes
baby yes when ya know who and someone
freaky I know is but yeah he comes in
that seems still legitimately scared you
know that's okay you see Peter McNichol
dressed as a nanny with red eyes yeah
the weird mr. fantastic arm so um yeah
can't get any I don't know I don't know
that's my stock Hollywood reaction is
either a very cautious
I don't know or just like kiss you
Jarama not like fingers crossed do you
know I think that's always go in with
kind of fingers crossed but yeah but now
you know why in certain areas we don't
care into all their areas really yeah
some people come up through the couldn't
believe all female cancer I don't care
or cablecast it's like we kind of did
that you know it's gonna i'm loving at
one extreme with another critics dream
that's part of the problem is giving
that's so big now maybe this is
different subsets of groups fighting or
like what the minute is through they
might have gotten the shaft for several
years what we need to evil the men on
this ER hence the all-female cast and
then i know there is some subset of like
feminists are upset that now they're
gonna do an all-male cast is I know we
finally get a female cast is like you
can't even have that it's like now we
have to do a male cast just to appease
rigid and then there's some people that
just like us think the whole idea is
just kind of dumb but at least a female
cast is new and then you know there's
too many of us maybe we should just step
away from our keyboards outside yeah
it's beautiful the beautiful day do it
in here
I don't know let's go for a walk
ghostbusters oh that's cool let's come
back in